And now, we briefly
interrupt our critique
of the extra silly to salute
someone extra special.
Now, if I suggested a sport
that literally drained your body
of life sustaining
oxygen, edging
you to the very
brink of existence,
you'd probably say, no thanks.
But then you're not
Alessia Zecchini,
aiming to dive
deeper on one breath
than any female freediver
has before in her category.
[plop]
Even at the surface, the average
person runs out of breath
after little more than
a minute, but Alessia
is far from average.
[music playing]
And down at 351 feet, almost
the length of a football
field, she breaks the record,
surfacing after a single breath
hold of 3 and 1/2 minutes.
[cheering]
It's easy to forget how
dangerous swimming under water
can be.
It can feel tranquil,
almost womb like,
[thud]
until you hit a problem,
which in free diving
can result in oxygen
starvation, nitrogen
narcosis,
decompression sickness,
blackout, all the bad stuff.
But while I wouldn't advise
trying to beat Alessia's
record, I would
recommend learning
the science behind the feat.
As our freediver dives, his
body consumes its oxygen supply,
which can lead to a
potentially lethal blackout.
In his favor is an
evolutionary response
called "the mammalian
dive reflex," which
diverts oxygen-rich blood to
the vital organs and reduces
the heart rate, lowering
oxygen consumption.
Efficient monofin
technique also helps.
Its large surface area
displaces a lot of water,
propelling him forwards
with minimal effort,
thereby conserving oxygen.
OK, nearly ready to
break some records?
It's time for a quick kit check.
Flippers work on
the same principle
as monofins, displacing
water to generate propulsion.
[splash]
Not so good on land, though.
All right, let's dive down where
the mammalian dive reflex kicks
in, even at shallow depths.
[music playing]
Not exactly what I meant
by mammalian dive reflex.
And while they'll still be
experiencing the reflex,
they're rather wasting its
oxygen-conserving effects.
That's better.
Making the most
of the propulsion
generated by his flippers
with gentle rhythmic kicks,
conserving precious oxygen
for the swim back up,
or for riding a bike.
OK, let's head up, but calmly
and oxygen efficiently so as
to avoid that thing
all free divers fear.
I was actually thinking
of "blacking out,"
but on that evidence,
I think we should leave
Alessia's record well alone.